Today the greatest risk of global catastrophe
doesn’t look like this.
Instead  it looks like this.
One of the most frustrating aspects of the
novel coronavirus pandemic
is how many early warning signs and response
plans for just such an event were waved away
by public health officials, the president,
governors,
and just about everyone else who could have
made a difference.
The George W. Bush administration nearly put
in place a pandemic preparedness plan...
I’m here to discuss our strategy to protect
and prevent the American people
from a possible outbreak.
And then let it drop.
What a problem, came out of nowhere.
It’s important to underscore that all the
death and economic wreckage COVID-19 has caused
didn’t just “come out of nowhere”
because there’s another totally predictable
crisis
that promises to be even more damaging to
our way of life.
The national debt—the amount of money that
the federal government owes—
is already choking down economic growth,
but in the future it could lead to a “sudden
inflation,”
and “a loss of confidence in the federal
government’s ability or commitment
to repay  its debts in full,”
and “such a crisis could spread globally.”
That’s according to the nonpartisan Congressional
Budget Office,
which has been warning Americans for years about the
long-term consequence of the ballooning debt.
Like the coronavirus, the debt problem has
the potential to seemingly appear out of the blue
and turn our world upside down in a matter
of weeks.
There’s plenty we can do to avoid or minimize
the potential shock to our system,
but congress and presidents from both major
parties
have accepted Dick Cheney’s false maxim
that “deficits don’t matter.”
Instead, they just keep spending more than
we take in even during the good times,
and being so deeply in hock will make us less
able to deal with a future crisis.
The amount of money the government owed to
the public was 79 percent of Gross Domestic Product
at the end of 2019, up from 31 percent in
2001.
The COVID-19 Lockdown and emergency spending
will push the curve above 100 percent of
GDP by the end of 2020
and it’s expected to keep rising.
Emergency spending and plunging tax revenues
are making a bad situation worse.
The Congressional Budget Office forecasts
that the budget deficit this year
will be  17.9 percent of GDP,
meaning that the government is running much
larger deficits
than it did even at the height of the financial
crisis.
Economists, such as Nobel prize-winner Paul
Krugman and proponents of modern monetary theory
look at the absence of inflation and higher
interest rates so far
as justification for ever-more spending and
borrowing.
While it’s true that the cost of paying
interest on the debt
is still dwarfed by other expenditures,
that’s because historically low interest
rates have made government borrowing cheap.
But there’s no reason to believe that interest
rates won’t rise over time.
According to conservative estimates from the
Congressional Budget Office,
as the total budget grows as a percentage
of GDP,
the cost of paying interest on the  debt will increase faster,
until it accounts for about 24 cents of every
dollar spent by 2050.
And these estimates don’t take into account
emergency spending for COVID-19,
which will make servicing the debt even more
costly over time.
Like a monthly credit card payment that eats
into a household budget,
federal debt means less money to buy other
things.
And when governments run large, persistent
deficits,
it also has a devastating impact on economic
growth over time.
Our current debt levels could reduce Gross
Domestic Product by about one quarter over 23 years,
according to research by Harvard economists
Carmen Reinhart and Kenneth Rogoff.
It’s a case of what French economist Frédéric
Bastiat referred to as “the unseen”
because we’ll never get to experience how
much wealthier we otherwise would have been
had the federal government practiced fiscal
prudence.
Anemic growth will impact the poorest American’s
most of all,
causing their material progress to slow considerably.
It means less leisure time, smaller homes,
older cars, and less health care.
In the short-term, there’s no question
that the government can and will be able to borrow massively,
and interest rates are likely to stay low
for the time being as the world shifts into recession.
But there’s also the specter of investors
here and abroad
refusing to buy US-issued debt as our economy
flattens,
China flexes its economic and political might,
and alternative instruments such as bitcoin
and gold offer safe refuge.
Like a global pandemic, a debt crisis seems
impossibly off in the distance
until it’s the only thing you can see.
Even the most hubristic economist or president
would have to admit
that there will come a time when the U.S.
dollar is no longer the world’s reserve currency.
That change won’t necessarily be as dramatic
as when German paper marks became worthless
after World War I,
but it will massively reduce purchasing power
even as it increases the cost of everything.
Spending proponents sometimes cite World War
II when talking about battling COVID-19
and the analogy is apt for reasons they may
not intend.
Between 1940 and 1945, federal spending increased
tenfold from $10 billion
to over $100 billion to pay for the war effort.
But when victory was won, the government immediately
cut military spending.
Once peace-time growth resumed, the debt-to-GDP
ratio fell quickly.
But starting in the 1970s, with the exception
of a 5-year dip during the economic boom of the 1990s,
the federal government has been growing the
size of the debt in relation to GDP.
Instead of a foreign enemy,
our out-of-control spending has been driven
by the persistent rise in the cost of entitlements
such as Medicare and Social Security.
Even as total tax revenues increase, we keep
spending more and more,
adding to a national debt that costs more
to service even as it reduces economic growth.
Despite seemingly just showing up in America
without notice,
the coronavirus pandemic and all that has
happened over the past two months
didn’t “just come out of nowhere.”
It was there all along, barely lurking in
the shadows.
When the debt crisis materializes and our
options are severely limited
because of decades of profligate spending,
politicians sitting in the Oval Office and
Congress
will claim that it all just came out of nowhere,
like that crazy virus back in 2020.
But nothing could be farther from the truth:
Budget wonks are sounding the alarm.
We need to heed these warnings now
or suffer an economic lockdown later from
which there may be no escape.